but first over a hundred flood warnings
are in place across the UK as many homes
and communities continue to come to
terms with flooding caused by storms
Kyra and Dennis
well we're joined now from central
London by the Environment Secretary
George Eustace thank you very much for
being on the show this morning mr.
Louis's hundreds of families are dealing
with the devastation of floods we've
seen homes in places like Yorkshire is
called a valley who've suffered from six
floods in the last five years
what reassurances can you give these
people on the show this morning that
government has got a grepolis situation
well sadly with climate change these
kinds of extreme weather events are
becoming more frequent we know if you
look at the long-run trends that weather
events like this are increasing in their
frequency each year and all we can
really do is try to improve our flood
defences and improve our response so
over the last five years we spend over
two-and-a-half million pounds on over
600 flood projects that's provided
protection to over 200,000 homes and
there's more to come and well it's been
a terrible flood event these last two
weeks the ground has been waterlogged
we've had two consecutive storms and
some 2,000 plus homes flooded as a
result we have also during that period
protected some 50,000 homes with the
measures we've taken in the last five
years and looking forward we want to do
even more so we're committed to spending
over four billion pounds on additional
flood defences in the next five years so
I can't help thinking the government
talks a good game when it comes to flood
defences but just to pick up on the two
and a half billion pounds funding that
you've been talking about that was
introduced from 2015 up to 60% of that
is going to be spent around London
rather than in places like Yorkshire
which is suffering and that is because
flood defence spending the formula for
it is dependent on property prices so of
course as a result it disproportionately
benefits homes in the southeast how can
that be fair well I don't really think
that's right we we had direct our flood
defense spending into areas that are at
greatest risk and where the money will
protect the greatest number of
that does mean that some of the big
projects tend to be in our urban areas
but it's important to note that around
25% of all our flood spending has gone
to Yorkshire that's in recognition of
the fact the Yorkshire is at risk of
flooding and indeed last weekend I
visited York and I saw the Faust barrier
and there's been some significant
investment in that in order to improve
its capacity in the last five years so I
don't accept that we're not investing in
other areas but there's always more that
we want to do and that's why in the next
five years we're going to be spending
even more on flood defences and
crucially as well looking at nature
based solutions so moving upstream to
try to slow the flow of water down to
our urban areas in the first place using
dams and trees and natural floodplains
and the like so just to clarify you're
saying that is incorrect to say that
property prices help to determine the
flood defense formulas funding well my
understanding is the formula that is
applied by the Environment Agency is
looking at the number of homes that can
be protected from a given scheme and
that is why it is understandable that
your heart defenses in urban areas will
tend to be in your larger centers of
population because an investment there
will protect the greatest number of
homes but it's not universally the case
and Yorkshire has been a big recipient
of flood defence spending York alone
we've been spending around 70 million
pounds to provide protections in the
city of York and indeed upstream you can
see why though some people outside of
London would feel that if this was
happening in London in some of these big
cities closer to the politicians in
Westminster more would be done I mean
where is the Prime Minister this week
well look when I was a pointed a week
ago on Thursday the prime minister when
he met me the first thing he said is
there are some storms coming up storm
dennis is coming this weekend we know
the impacts are going to be
what action we would take it was agreed
that I would make a visit to look at uh
preparedness over that weekend it's not
true that the Prime Minister's had not
been engaged in this from the very
moment he appointed me he's been engaged
we stood up a National Flood Response
Center and they've been daily conference
calls that I've led and you know in a
cabinet government it's not a one-man
show it's right there on certain
operational things such as this the
Prime Minister will ask one of his
cabinet members to lead I can't see
anything wrong with that
I don't think anyone's disputing the
fact that it would be a you know a
one-man show but at the same time Boris
Johnson hasn't been seen in public for
nine days when there were floods back in
November he visited the affected areas
he called an emergency committee for the
government's Cobra committee why do you
think it is that he would do those
things during an election campaign and
not now well what happened on that
particular incident in the election is
because it was an election and there
were no ministers and we were in what's
called a a perder period where there was
less ministerial involvement in the
department there was seem to be
something of a slow start in a response
to that particular incident and that's
why because of the criticism the prime
minister in that instance did stand up
Cobra I think that's not being necessary
this time because we actually have sadly
because of the regular occurrence of
flood events we have something called
the national flood response center
hosted in the Cabinet coordinates across
government coordination and action on
these things that's been stood up over
ten days now and has been leading all of
the response to this so you didn't need
to stand up a separate Cabinet Office
infrastructure in the form of Cobra
because you already had one dedicated to
floods that was operating and you began
the interview talking about how extreme
weather is going to become more of a
frequent event connect government really
do anything to stop people's homes being
flooded or is this just an inevitability
of the world we're in
well it's I think inevitable that we're
going to get more of these extreme
weather events of course we have to do
our bit to try to tackle climate change
and as a country we are we've led it's
flooding in amphoteric we've led the
world
well flooding it's the frequency of it
these weather events of course is
inevitable because we've already got
climate change it's important that we do
our bit to mitigate that by leading the
world as we are in terms of reducing our
carbon emissions and decarbonizing our
economy and we're one of the first we
see the economies to actually commit to
net zero by 2050 but when it comes to
flooding there is more we want to do and
that is why we've committed to spend
another four billion pounds over the
next five years particularly looking at
some of those nature based solutions
where we can slow down the flow of water
hold water upstream use soft dams have
natural flood plains so that the water
is less likely to get to our urban
centers in the first place but we'll
never be able to protect every single
home it's important that we recognize
that but what we can do is do more and
more to protect as many homes as
possible okay
now the UK is going to this week publish
its negotiating mandate with the EU for
those upcoming trade talks the negotiate
negotiating bandit with the US we're
expecting the week after now your
predecessor in the job Tereza video said
last month that we will not be importing
chlorinated chicken we will not be
importing hormone treated beef will you
make the same commitment
[Music]
well look the truth is that it's already
illegal in this country to say it to
sell chlorine wash chicky and nor indeed
hormone beef that's in our legislation
but the important thing I would say is
we believe very passionately in this
country about food standards and our
animal welfare standards we worked very
hard over the last 20 years to build
quite a sophisticated market where
there's a lot of consumer confidence in
the provenance of our food and how it
was produced and the safety of our food
and we're absolutely clear as a
government that we will not take risks
either with our food standards and that
when it comes to animal welfare we will
be projecting our views on animal
welfare on the international stage it's
the UK that's been a world leader in
animal welfare particularly farmed
animal welfare and we want to bring the
rest of the world along with us so you
send that answer that it's currently
illegal to have chlorinated treatment a
chlorinated chicken or hormone treated
beef but of course when you've got a big
majority you can change that if you
wanted to so can you give a commitment
that even if the u.s. demanded it in a
trade deal it's a red line that we
wouldn't cross well I'm not quite sure
why the US would make such demands
because actually chlorine washes on
chicken are a very outdated technology
and it's not really used by the US
anymore in a way what they tend to use
these days are lactic acid washes and we
need even in this country we'll use well
what I'm saying is we won't make any
moves on our standards we've got a clear
position in this country that it is
illegal to sell chlorine wash chicken
illegal to sell beef treated with
hormones with no plans to change those
things but equally as I would say it's
not the case that the u.s. currently
used chlorine was chicken anyway okay
and now moving on to immigration because
we've got a bit more guidance on what
the post 4x8 immigration policy will
look like for this government and it's
all about restricting what the
government determines to be kind of
low-skilled workers of course one of the
sectors that relies heavily
workers from abroad is agriculture and
if you restrict the number of workers
that comes for abroad it's not going to
hit farmers and basically force people
into buying more food from overseas well
the government recognizes that
agriculture is a special case and that's
why what we've also announced in the
past week is that we're going to
quadruple the size of the seasonal
agricultural workers scheme to ten
thousand initially this year it's very
important that certain sectors such as
soft root vegetables and salad
production
they're quite reliant on seasonal labor
that's people who come here to work
maybe for six months before returning
home and we recognize that's entirely
different to people migrating to the UK
to settle permanently that's why a
seasonal agricultural worker scheme is
important and will be an important part
of our immigration policy in the future
so you mentioned that you're quadrupling
the number but that only takes the total
to 10,000 I mean the National Farmers
Union says we need 70,000 workers every
year it's nowhere near enough was it
well this was two half thousand last
year this is a second year of a pilot
and we've increased it to ten thousand
and of course the completion of that
pilot it's not this year no but they
don't need seventy thousand this year
because we still have free movement for
the remainder of 2020 and they will be
able to recruit the other staff that
they need from countries such as Romania
and in particular Bulgaria as they do as
they have done in previous years the
important thing will be in the future
and obviously the pilot will end this
year and will be in a position to roll
out a fully fledged seasonal
agricultural workers scheme that can be
designed to provide the needs of the
agricultural and horticultural sector
you see the government says it wants to
bring down low skilled immigration many
people would see perhaps a more accurate
description of that as low paid jobs
rather than low skilled jobs why is it
that high skilled jobs are highly paid
jobs should go to people from overseas
whereas the low paid ones who reserve
for bread
well I think the important thing to
recognize here is we want as a country
to do strike a different course on our
immigration policy rather than having
what we've had in recent years which is
effectively complete free movement with
EU countries and then quite a restricted
regime for the rest of the world it's
important that we are consistent and
that we have an approach based on skills
and that we enable people to come here
from wherever they might live if they
have the right skills to contribute to
our economy so identifying those areas
where we have a skill shortage whether
it might be vets whether it might be NHS
staff whether it might even be chefs or
people who do specialist welding
identifying those types of skills where
we have a gap and allowing people to
come to work in those sectors is a
logical approach rather than having free
movement and a complete free-for-all
with the European Union I mean the Home
Secretary said that they could have you
know a skilled jobs shortages could be
filled by the 8.5 million people classed
as economically inactive but according
to the Office of National Statistics
most of those people who are
economically inactive students carers
they've got long term illnesses or
they're retired yes I don't think the
Home Secretary was saying that all 88
million of those people would be able to
fill these just sir there are people
there who might and I think that's right
there will be some people who perhaps
retired but would like to still take a
part-time job there are students of
course who take a part-time job as well
so she's not saying that the all of
those 8 million people can work as she
was saying that there are a pool there
of people who could do some and I think
that's a perfectly legitimate point to
make but a more important point is
obviously we're going to keep an eye on
all of these things at the moment there
are over 3.2 million EU citizens who've
already applied for settled status here
in the UK so they will be staying so
those are already working here and
living here can stay and as we look
forward we can then judge what our needs
are at the moment we don't think there's
a need to open a route for so-called low
skilled occupations but we'll be
being a very close eye on this and see
how things develop over the next couple
of years and the beauty of being outside
of the European Union is you have that
flexibility as a country to set your
immigration policy and to modify it as a
when required to ensure that it's fit
for purpose and then just finally and
you've been in the Department for before
of course and but you've only recently
been appointed Environment Secretary so
I'm just quite interested to hear your
views on foxhunt I'm sorry I'm
interested to know your views on fox
hunting a fox hunting well as a
government we're not going to change the
Fox
you know fox hunting the the ban on
hunting with dogs it's been in place now
quite a long time there's been arguments
batted in a number of general elections
it's always been a free vote issue and
there was a point in history when the
Conservatives said that they would offer
a free vote on hunting in government
time that's no longer the position we
think there's a new settlement now on
fox hunting that the the ban on hunting
the dog should stay in place okay thank
you very much for being on the program
this morning thank you